hello everyone very excited to be here
today uh thank you for being here so
yeah so we're going to talk about how to
build an advanced visual search engine
with self-supervised learning
representations and milvis
so quick quote about ourselves my name
is Noe I work as a lead data scientist
at secara I've been there since 2020 uh
work mostly on computer vision and I'm a
big fan of volleyball and tennis
and I am Antoine and I work at Cara 2
for six years now
and I am head of science at Chicago
so just a quick disclaimer we're not
researchers so we're going to share some
results we got on some projects some
opinions we have but there is no
scientific paper behind it
so yeah so we're gonna build a visual
search engine based on the similarity of
representations so it's just a system
where you input an image and it outputs
the images that look the most similar
from your database
so some examples of where such stem
could be great is when for instance if
you want to validate if a person's photo
in your database so imagine you're a big
company who wants to authenticate your
employees in front of the building
or if your Google lens and you want to
whenever someone take a picture of your
clothes you want to match it to the most
similar clothes in your database
or just if you have a huge database of
images at your companies and you really
don't know how to leverage its potential
so you just input an image and it will
allow you to retrieve the most similar
images
so now Antoine is going to talk to you
about how image retrieval works yeah so
imagine credit score is the underlying
task behind the certain lines actually
so it's it simply consists of retrieving
an image in a large image database
provided a query that could be either a
text or a keyword or
an image
when the query is an image it's called
content based image retrieval and that's
really what we are going to talk about
today so how do we build such a system
the idea is that we rely on a feature
structure which is a model which can be
a neural network or something else
actually and what it does is that it
extracts from an image a representation
that is a vector
that describes the image
so we use the feature text extractor to
extract a presentation from the query
and all the image the images of the
database so we have a large number of
image representation from the database
and the idea is to to compute similarity
scores between those representation
how do we do that we have a several
method to do that a very simple one is
to use distance like cosine distance or
L1 L2
and once you have a similarity scores
between the query image representation
and the representation of the image
database you can simply retrieve the
most similar image by ranking those
scores and
showing the image accordingly
so when building such a system there are
two challenges so the first one is to
have a good feature extractor
because if the representation are not
good you are not going to be able to to
to do good searches
uh there was a famous problem in
computer vision a few years ago some
people try to to train a classifier to
classify walls and dogs and they figured
out at some point that the even if the
performance was quite good the model was
using the snow to classify walls because
there was a bias in the in the data set
so imagine you you have a feature sector
that describes the the snow in the
representation but not the The Wharf and
you want to look to search for wolves in
your image database it will not work
the the Second Challenge you you may
have enter is that
when you have a large number of image in
your database it can be a challenge to
to build a production ready system to to
compute similarities at scale and to
serve the results to the end user
so another way is going to we are going
to to talk about the Third change and
how to build a good image representation
and now it's going to
show you the the first step for that
so yeah so when uh starting any project
the first thing you want to do is
building a baseline so we're going to
see how to build a baseline for this
image representations
so a common thing to do when you're
building a model for any task is in
computer vision is that you take a model
it's free trained on the live data set
like imagine it or open images and then
you fight you need on your custom data
so so is that you adapt your model to
your custom domain and your custom task
so we're gonna see if we can get a
decent performance without actually fine
tuning on our custom data and taking
just end of the chef model to get a
Baseline
so to see to do that we're going to
check if we can classify images doing
content based image retrieval images
which are very far apart from the
training distribution so from the
distribution of imagenet so microscopic
bacteria images which are not seen in
imagenet
so why doing so it's actually a real use
case we faced so we we are actually
still working for a company called uh
video Rica
and they it's a startup that want to
classify a picture of bacteria images
and there is actually a high complexity
in the data uh even within the same
class because there could be different
type of microscopes different zooms uh
different reactants which are used to
to exploit the bacteria so and there are
no data to start with and since it's a
startup they want to move fast so
collecting and labeling the large data
sets is not really feasible
so we are wondering if we could use
content-based image retrieval so on a
with a pre-trained model and
to confirm our ID we used a data set
called gbas which contained 33 classes
of bacterias and 20 images per class
so and it has a quite low complexity
because it's only one type of Zoom one
type of microscope images from the same
class they use the same reactants
so it's really a subset of our full
complexities but if we can get something
working on that we can deduce that model
pre-train on one of these large data
sets would be able to extract the
required features from bacteria images
someone actually trained the model for
for this task they use the mobile net V2
which is a quite small model since they
have very few data you can't really use
a big model to to train it on big model
uh they so they pre-trained it on
imaginates and then fine tune so they
train the classification layer with 10
images per class and evaluated yourself
on the 10 remaining Mages which led to a
performance of 95 which is quite good
because the task is quite easy
and
um then in our experiments we perform
content-based image retrievals so
basically just choose a model train on
imaginates compute image representations
and match these representations
so at training our model has never seen
any bacteria images
and what we see is that when we use a
mobile net V2 we get a result of 80. and
we can get this performance up to 84
percent when we use better backbones
but it's still far from the 95 percent
but also it's very far away from random
so what we can see here is that it
really manages to extract some
interesting features to give an
interesting performance
so a good way to check why
um
why this model is actually working is to
visualize the projection in a
tensorboard
so I'm gonna check it now and so each
representation are the size
1408 and you just project it in a 3D
space
uh doing dimensionality reduction so
it's PCA but Destiny works much better
so I'm just going to stop it after a few
iterations so tesney is just trying to
clusterize the images that look similar
and you can really see the cluster of
images so I can color them with the
class and basically images of the same
class have the same color and if they
are close to each other it means that in
the future space the model represents
them close from each other so like our
content based image retrieval system
will manage to classify the model
so it works quite well like the the
different colors are really clusterized
you can see that sometimes some colors
are very close to each other and if we
click on these example so this is one of
the cluster
this is the other cluster and you can
see that the image look very similar
even for human eye it starts to
differentiate them since the model
wasn't trained on that it's quite easy
to understand why it's making some
mistakes
so how to create such projection it's a
bit harder with tensorflow but much
easier with paytash
so you just use the simulator from the
tensorboard plugin created and then
called the atom bidding method with your
Matrix of embeddings your images and
some metadata like the classes to uh to
create it and then you can you can
launch that and you get this great
representation you can click on testing
epci and there are many other things you
can explore
so to the question when we classify
microscopic bacterial images using a
pre-trained model on imagenet with no
fine tuning the answer is yes
so to conclude this virtual this first
challenge Antoine is going to talk to
you about how we can improve these
representations with self supervised
learning and visual Transformers
thank you so the first thing you may ask
is why what has SSL and vision
Transformer has to do with imagery River
and this ID can uh when we read this
paper like two years ago I think yeah
maybe you've heard of it it's quite
famous it's a paper called Dino
and it talks about uh cell supervised
learning and vision Transformers
here is the main table of results from
the paper
so they are
several methods that are compared
supervised and unsupervised methods and
also different feature Factor
n50 stands for resnet 50. so it's a
convolutional net and vision
Transformers
the the last two columns linear on k n
uh describe the the method to evaluate
the model and imagine it linear it
simply consists of adding a classifying
layer on top of the feature structure
and fine-tuning it
and K N it's a bit more challenging it's
directly performing a classifying task
in the unbeading space out of the
feature extractor so in the image
representation space
but it's much closer to the image
retrieval task which is interesting for
us to build our visual certain lines
so if we look at the the linear
performance what we can see is that
the first line is the supervised
Baseline and then you have a list of
cell supervised methods and what you can
see that they are a steady increase in
the performance within the earth and the
the dino line was two years ago so now
the performance is even better than that
and what is remarkable about these
results is that it achieves that without
requiring any levels
so to understand how it it does that we
we should dive a little bit into the
linear algorithms
and see how it learns good
representation so here I choose a
honorably an image that is going to to
be seen during the training phase
so the first thing we do is to extract
crops Global crops that is a the huge
bottom crops and small crops
and we perform data augmentation on them
like a color Jitter or flips
classical augmentations
and the idea is that by doing so we we
build several views of the same object a
bit like if you were there and you took
picture with your with your phone and
moving around the monument and when do
you you have this different view we
put this image into our feature sector
and we will get representations
and the training objective is to make
this representation being the same
and by doing so we force the model to to
to Anchor the visual features that are
common between the global crop and the
local crops
into the representation for instance
this one you have a horse
so maybe the model is going to have
something in the representation that
will uncut the horse which also appear
in the global crops
and small crops and big crops are
extracted randomly so that in the end
you end up with a representation that
will uh describe everything that is
visible in the image
and it does that without requiring any
level
and something really interesting in the
in the dino paper and it was surprising
to the hotel themselves is that when you
use a vision Transformer and only Vision
Transformer it does not work this way
with confidence
the the canine performance
came very close to
the performance you got when you do fine
tuning and this is really interesting
for us because when we do we build our
search engine
we we compute the nearest neighbor in
the representation space we do not
perform any fine tuning so this is very
interesting for us
is going back to the the bacteria
example and show you what SSL and vision
Transformers
on this point
thank you again so yeah so you're
getting familiar with this slide now we
are asking ourselves can we get even
better representations with Dino
uh so just quickly looking at the
results
I did two line at the bottom uh you can
see that you actually get a better
performance than with supervised
backbones
um it's quite quite interesting like the
difference is not big not that we're
using 10 images per class to represent
each class when this number is getting
lower so if using just one or two images
to represent each class the difference
get bigger
still far away from a model pre-trained
trained actually on this data which kind
of makes sense an interesting thing is
that we are not confirming here that uh
using visual Vision Transformer gives a
better performance and confidence but it
might be because the task is easy so now
let's just let's just conclude so the
answer is yes again
and let's just let's jump to a task
which is a bit harder
of course here the distribution is
closer from what we see in imaginates
but it's much harder because there are
many many more images
so there are
762k index images so images in the
database and around 100 and K classes so
if you if you did a bit of math around
seven to eight images per class
um and
um yeah so a lot there are just too many
images too many classes and too few
images per class to train a
classification layer so you have to
perform content-based image retrieval
uh there is around 1K uh test images and
these images are collected on Wikipedia
so there are a lot of label errors
um so this is what they did on the paper
so they trained model with uh their
their data sets and what you see on the
test set is that they get 25 percent of
mini average precision and one then
train it on an other data set which
contains landmarks so same task just not
that's it which is not as good they get
about half of the performance
and in our experiments again we are
taking an off-the-shelf model so
pre-train on imaginets and what we see
here is really that Vision Transformer
with Dino we've trained with the dino
method uh really gives the best
performance as I states in the paper
uh not that this performance is about
half the performance of of uh when you
train It actually on Landmark images on
this specific task
so now we're gonna try to understand why
this performance is lower and why Vision
Transformer Trend with Dino give better
performance that Vision Transformer
train in a supervised fashion
so just a quick zoom on visual
Transformer so this is a video from from
Dino
and one interesting thing is that
um
Vision Transformer are based on
attention mechanisms like something you
may have heard about called chat GPT
and
so since it's based on uh on attention
mechanisms you get an output
representation
and you can really check uh you can
really see where this output
representation puts its focus on so
which part of the image uh it carries
its attention on so if you look at the
dock for instance the output
representation really looks at the
entire dog and not at anything else and
on all of these images it has really a
human way of doing why it managed to
like not pay any attention to what's not
important
and really look at what's what seems
important in the image like even though
we haven't told it to
so if we come back to our model
pre-trained on Imaginext
and uh so the first line are the
attention maps of
visual Vision Transformer trained
imaginate on a supervised fashion and
you can see that the attention maps are
very noisy they are very erratic looking
a bit everywhere in the image and when
you look at attention maps with dinner
they really focus on the object of
Interest almost like a segmentation map
so even though we haven't told it what's
important it it finds it itself
so it's quite uh
it's one of the reason why the model
train with the the vision Transformer
Trend with Dino
gives better representation than uh the
vision Transformer trained in a
supervised fashion
so if we have a quick look at um
a dashboard which I spoiled a bit at the
beginning so made with stream leads so
you can just
input and image so on the left you see
the query image
you will see at the bottom so the
attention maps superposed to this image
and at the bottom at the very bottom
just the right tension Maps and on the
right it's the images from the database
so the
762k images which are the most similar
to my query image
so you can see I input a castle it gave
me castles so it's quite good uh
interesting to see that the attention is
really carried on the flag so it outputs
images which have flags as well
so yeah it's um quite interesting to see
so attention maps are great for to
analyze the performance of your models
of course I Come From Paris so I have to
show the FL Tower and what's uh
what's interesting with it so it's a bit
of a large image so it takes a bit of
time to compute the tension map sorry
but what's interesting with it is that
it's such a famous picture so of course
it will be in the data sets so we get
exact matches for this one
and really again the attention map is
really segmenting the the FL Tower
because it was interesting in this image
um when I was talking about the fact
there were a lot of labeling errors in
these data sets this image is actually
not labeled a filter like the others but
well which is the bridge just in front
so quite impossible to get it right
and we are not in Paris we are in uh
Berlin so I have to show the bronberg
turf my German is not uh on points
but also an interesting result so again
it it didn't see this Imaging is
training it was turned on the imaginary
so we're just trying to extract the
feature of Interest
and it's really focusing on the horses
pattern at the top
uh with what you find interesting and of
course the pillars so the first images
which are found are like images we like
pillow like structure and very quickly
it managed to find the exact match so
the brandburg Thor because it focuses as
well on the horses pattern so like even
though it's a completely different view
it's very corrupt it managed to match
them
and now we're gonna have a look at kind
of the limitation of this method
so
it was never trained to match landmarks
so he's just trying to match what seems
interesting to it so if I just input the
top view which will appear in uh in a
second
what seems interesting to hear to the
model is the file attitude sub View and
not the file that is this specific
Landmark so it will just match the views
so it's really one limitation of the of
this approach which may explain why we
get such a smaller such a lower
performance than when we actually train
a model on this specific task
another an interesting thing to see ish
is this image
where there is a huge side in front of
the landmark and you can see that the
model is really focusing the attentions
are really focusing on the sign so it's
not at all matching uh building uh
buildings which should look like this
one but other but really it matches uh
building with with signs on them
so it's really one of the limitations of
this approach we don't control what is
going to match
it's just focusing on something that's
interesting
um
one fun thing you can do is mixing up
representations so for instance you just
take two different images
you put them through the model uh you
get two image representations and you
just take the average of your two
representations and consider that it
comes from a confirm an image and to get
the most similar image
and so I kind of spoiled the first
result I'm going to show
if I just put this picture here
and this picture here
the first mod that is output is really a
mix of the two images
so really a castle with like the water
pattern in front so we will manage
actually to mix up the images
and then the other matches are
completely off so it could be either
that this approach is not working
perfectly well or just that there were
no other images in the data sets that
looked like buff image
and then I can have some fun doing uh
other stuff so if I put a bit image can
I actually get a castle on the beach
and uh yeah get off
so and the last one if I put remember
the image which was focusing on the sign
can I have a sign on the beach
so not in the first one but in the
second one I managed to get a sign on a
so quite quite fun thing to do and then
you can change the way to want to carry
on the first image for instance so to
put to have more weight on the second
image so now it kind of completely
forget the first image but really now
imagination is a limit like you can just
put three four Images have different
weights and it could be quite
interesting if you are looking for a
specific imagine a database like you're
inputting your first emails not quite
easy one you want so you're including a
single image
etc etc
so so far we are just two data
scientists in a garage but now we want
to have users and to make it accessible
to people so we're gonna try to deploy
it
yeah so I am the the production guy arms
and now we have to to put this in the
hand of the the hand users that can be
made many and another challenge is when
the the image database increase because
remember we have to compute
representation for all of this image and
compare the the query with all of them
so if we Implement a naive way of doing
this
so the complexity is actually linear in
in the number of the image in the
database
so we have to to find a way to cut the
complexity
one solution is an algorithm called the
approximate nearest neighbor so it's an
approximation it's not exact but it's
very fast and I will not enter the
detail but the ID is that it will
compute clusters of all the image
representations of the the database and
it will do so recursively so that to
build the tree in the left part and when
you have to you have a query
representation you simply go down in the
tree and you find the nearest neighbor
very
very fast
so if we sum up we need a tool to uh
first to to store the representation uh
if you have a lot of them you you want
to store them in a efficient way
we have to to index them index means
building the tree I showed you before
and not only you need to to build the
index at once but you also need to to
rebuild it when you for instance add new
images to the database or remove some
and finally you need to to be able to
perform search in this database in a
efficient way if you have many users
that do simultaneously
simultaneous search
so we identify a solution that is called
milvas it's a vector database that that
tackle releases these points when we we
were looking for a solution we consider
our first elastic search because we we
use it a lot at hikara
and it's it's very good and it can
handle vectors and it also has
approximate nearest neighbor algorithms
the but it was not fast enough for our
needs so we switched to milvers which is
a really specialized for vectors and
each it is a faster
there is also face it's a python Library
implemented by um Meetup and it's really
focused on the the index algorithms it
does not provide a database to serve the
predictions
uh there is also another solution that
is called acute runs which is written in
rest
and it seems according to to pude runs
that they are faster than milvis
we didn't consider this option at the
time because
because it was a really starting project
and milvis was a lot more popular
but right now maybe we should check
quadrant
and now on the way it's going to to show
you how we deploy a millbus the
different options
so basically there are if you want now
to deploy middle verse on your project
there are two different options the
first one is like the easy version the
easy one is a standalone version so it's
simple and it's very ideal for testing
so you just have a Docker compose that
comes with Melvis since it's open source
with free services
the first one is the middle Standalone
so it's just basically all these micro
Services packaged in one to make it
simple then you get one service for the
object storage which will contain all
your
all your image representations and a key
value store and Etc which will basically
be the database that's allowed to handle
the main interactions
but when you want to deploy it to
Productions and to uh to better manage
the performance and memory Etc the
cluster version is more adapted but it's
more complex because all these
microservices are deployed individually
on top of that there is also a log
broker that comes with it so Kafka or
Pulsar which allows to receive the
different request on the user and
process them accordingly
so of course there are tools to help you
like if you're doing kubernetes
handshots and stuff but still quite hard
to manage like don't do it if you don't
have a devops team
um
one great thing about milvers that it
comes with a web interface called R2
which allows you to manage your
different collections so right now I
have only one which is my collection
which contain all my image
representation of a girl one Mac V2 and
it's great to see if everything works
and do some testing and some managing
we are in pi data so I have to show some
python code
so here's just some quick code of how to
and how to interact with the milvis SDK
so it's very similar to elasticsearch or
any database really if you if you worked
with some so you first have to connect
to it then you create a shimmer of your
different fields which will be your
metadata and you create your collection
then you insert your data in equipment
of a line of codes
and then you call the create index
method which will basically run the
proximate Universe neighbor to index or
data and make them easily searchable
to when when you have indexed all of
that searching your data is equally
simple so again you have to connect
then you have to load the collection
loading the collection means taking it
from disk to CPU
to make it searchable and then you call
the search method with your query
representation to
um
to be able to search it
if we have just one quick look quick
last look at the dashboard you can see
that there are this extra line so the
because of it was Midwest that was
working behind it so for those of you
who write early and some is traveling
with the dodgeball at the beginning is
because I forgot to launch the Android
uh so yeah so this is the handshine
behind it and it's searching among
762k images and it managed to find this
result in
0.032 seconds which is quite fast also
considering the Standalone version so it
can be even faster
uh um
so just quickly some pros and cons of
this solution if you're considering it
the first cons is as I said it's quite
hard to manage the cluster mode you need
to devops theme
and we Face some bugs uh
uh in the recent version we are facing
some birds which uh took us a lot of
time
mostly to the devops team and of course
there were fixed luckily in more recent
versions which are now stable but it
took some time to
to follow so for the prawns it's
scalable and fast
it's open source so it comes with many
advantages
there are many features like partitions
so for instance if you want to search in
a subset of your collection it's visible
a research Etc I won't go in all the
features there is a web interface as we
saw a strong Community to help you
a good documentation and a managed
version so if you don't have any devops
team I will really recommend just give
him some pennies to uh to Midwest so
that they deploy it for you and it makes
it much easier
so
so one of the main takeaways of today is
that we can build and email how to do
image retrieval with Dino pre-train on a
large data set like imagenets on the on
to test yourself on data set which I'll
actually show you from the distribution
which can be quite far away like dbas or
Google landmarks V2
and we saw how to deploy it into
production
so imagine retrieval can be great for
many tasks uh may need to start a
project as we saw with Bureau record
could be challenging to get enough data
to train a good model so you could
consider doing image retrieval
and SSL is great so self supervised
learning is great for many things as
well uh one one good
thing it could be good for is when you
have a project which has been in
production for a long time so you've
been just collecting millions of
unlabeled images and you don't really
know how to leverage a potential so you
can just use train it with supervised
learning
so
um yes but it comes with some defaults
and it's quite expensive to train but
yeah so what could we do to to improve
our search engine right now so obviously
we could use llms as a anybody right now
more seriously
before uh chat deputy there were daily
on multimodal models multi-model models
could be very helpful to to improve the
search engine line as they have a
represented common representations for
text and images
this would allow for instance to to have
more complexity in the the queries you
could query the database using a text or
an image or both
and
this last week Dino V2 was released
it's very similar to dino but the scaled
the model and the data set
so they train a much much larger model
I think it's a billion parameter model
something like that and they used that
to distill a smaller one so this is very
really inspired from what is going on on
llms right now
and it's really recent so we didn't try
it yet but uh it's the
it's uh similar to dino but with which
with much better image representations
so we can simply reuse all what we show
you today and plug you know V2 instead
of you know
so thank you very much
[Applause]
yes uh thanks a lot that was a great
talk
um I learned a lot of things and I think
all the people here on a lot of things
too we have a lot of questions so let's
um do some questions
do you have any insight on how do the
self-supervised dyno models manage to
focus on the most important parts of the
image
so if you have any insight on how do the
self-supervised dyno models manage to
focus on the most important parts of the
image okay
I think in the in the dinner algorithm
as I showed you the local crops and
Global crops the global crops are
almost the entire image but this is
really this really depends on the
training data set for in the imagenet
data set there is a bias that actually
there is always an object that is
Central to the image
like the the bone burger and when you do
a global crops that is almost the entire
image you always have parts of this
object which means that there is a
it's it's a really probable that you you
will have in the local crop some parts
of the global object but if you use
another data sets probably you have to
adjust this the size of the the crops
thank you now a difficult question how
would you check the quality of your
clustering if the number of classes is
in the thousands with more than 100 000
images
I think you can try to answer that so
it's very difficult this is why we
didn't do it for girl landmarks
I think what you can do is just select a
subset of images a subset of classes
just uh if you have if you did
classification you can check for
instance the cluster that perform the
worst I'll do that perform the best
compare them together do like some
confusion matrices and check which
clusters are mixing from each other so
you can definitely you cannot visualize
them all together but just visualize
what you need to visualize
thank you
um
how hard is it to maintain a movers
cluster in production do you need to be
an expert in kubernetes
so as I said in the project we use
milverse the
yes you they kind of had to be an expert
in uh in kubernetes
because there are a lot of micro
services and I try to debug it myself
I'm not an expert and I failed
and
um so yes so they can and even for
experts in kubernetes there are a lot of
micro Services which it's hard to
understand what they all do there are a
lot of logs to check so um now it's no
the bugs we faced are fixed so it's not
a problem anymore but I would still
recommend if you don't have a production
devops team to use the manage version so
to basically for you can yes there is a
service for Mill views where you can pay
them to deploy it on either AWS or gcp
that makes sense sometimes it's worth
spending some money another question
could you manually Mark regions to focus
on in the query image and use the local
features instead of those of the entire
query image
that's something we can we could do and
the easiest way to do this is to
actually if I if I wanted to do this
myself I would simply crop the the input
image so uh probably the easiest ways to
integralize this in the UI of your tool
like uh make it easy easy for the user
to crop its input image
uh now a special one What GPU did you
use to retrain Dino
we did not return dinner
it's uh it's trained on the as we said
we were using pre-trained models uh I
think uh Antoine tried to retrain you
know so you can talk about it we did it
once with a very small GPU I think it
was a RTX 2080 and it took
close to 200 days so don't do that
did you run the demo here locally
so the the index of free
762k images is quite big so it was
lagging on my computer so I did not run
it locally we have a machine at Sea Cara
where I just SSH to it so the all the
Computing of the representation Etc is
done on my computer but just the Midwest
engine is running uh in Paris okay one
last quick question most voted one do
you plan to open source any parts of
your implementation
uh if you want to we can but we need to
do some cleaning
thanks a lot for being here it was
really nice to have you
[Applause]